this is me making sushi 20 people why
because I'm co-hosting a big iftar
dinner that's the meal where Muslims
break though fast at the end of the day
during Ramadan
if this Ramadan first time in my life I
decided to my name is yaara and I work
at aj+ around the office I noticed a lot
of my co-workers getting ready for the
Muslim holy month of Ramadan which yes
on the outside means no TV no drinking
of smoking and no sex from dawn to dusk
and try to avoid swearing and bad
behavior throughout the month fasting is
not prescribed for anyone who's too
young too old sick traveling pregnant
breastfeeding or on their period ask
your mom if fasting is right for you
anyway
this has led some to think of Ramadan as
a sad joyless month of quiet suffering
people are saying oh my god you're
fasting all you have to not eat for a
whole day that's terrible do you think
it's almost like a punishment but if
someone who comes from a Muslim
background I know that's not the case I
have tons of friends and relatives who
fast and who happily look forward to
Ramadan every year for me it's dry it's
hella fun it's a time where everyone
gets
it's eveyone I haven't even so long it's
my favorite time of year
that's how I know there's this whole
other side to it it's a holiday that's
not only spiritual it's celebratory it's
fun and it's all about community thank
you so this year I figured I'd give
fasting a shot for the first time ever
to explore that side of Ramadan okay so
before I start fasting for Ramadan
there's one very important thing I need
to do that's talking to my Muslim
coworkers it's about building your power
I think you'll all persevere and come to
really appreciate it Ramadan is like the
most social event of the year
oh yes Ramadan in America in 2018 is a
big deal and there's a lot going on and
a lot of news before I attended any of
these events I had to talk to a Ramadan
professional a few moments like the
super driver avoid eating salty stuff
helpful people need hunger people and in
a month Ramadan is the model during
which the quran is been revealed
it's a month of forgiveness so we seek
the forgiveness of our lower throughout
fasting prayers at night from charity
and now with all these tips I was ready
to get started
the first thing I did was go shopping to
prepare for a super important meal the
sapore that's the other meal you eat
during Ramadan
besides the iftar dinner think of it as
breakfast but at like 4 a.m. it's the
very very very last time you can eat or
drink before the Sun goes up what tips
do you have for what I should eat for
support gonna wake up gonna be exhausted
you're gonna eat up an anti go back I
was a bit anxious so I spent the night
at my friend's house so he could show me
the ropes
that's tapash dudes been fasting for
like 15 years before I went to bed I
drank responsibly and then slowly
drifted into sleep now we have to make
this breakfast and then we sat and ate
until dawn
[Music]
I can't talk to you we have to eat down
to another two classes block yes so now
I have to go back to bed
well you won't see however is me waking
up to go to the bathroom to expel the
six classes water I just drink
[Music]
and so my first day of fasting began in
earnest I definitely felt pangs of
hunger and I got tired but it had been
flowed and I sort of just got used to it
especially after I immerse myself in
work I'm not gonna lie like a lot of
other people I did start counting down
the hours until I could break my fast
three hours left I got to do it the way
that make my grandma proud but it was
nice knowing that I was counting down
with a tiny community of fasters in the
office and an even bigger community of
the 3.5 million Muslims in the US and a
gigantic community of about 1.8 billion
Muslims around the world even among
Muslims in the u.s. fasting is super
popular nearly twice as many American
Muslims fast compared to those who pray
5 times a day
anyway for me fasting just got easier it
seemed like my body was adjusting and
the Tabo isn't slowed down and I just
didn't need as much food as I thought I
did and despite being surrounded by food
all day I felt a greater sense of
self-control
it felt empowering what I quickly
learned is that Ramadan is just as much
about eating as it is about fasting
every night you eat lots and lots of
food
with lots and lots of people close to
your heart after not eating for some 16
plus hours i sat down with friends
family and people from the local Muslim
community to share an enormous meal and
a conversation I never had a single
dinner alone by myself during the week I
spent documenting this and I made new
friends in the process and for my first
Ramadan I even participated in the great
American Muslim tradition of going to
high hop for support at 2:30 in the
morning raise your hand if you need
utensils but most days my suhoor was
something like this or worse I
accidentally set my alarm for 3:30 p.m.
which means I miss hora
I learned that one of the things I
personally love most about Ramadan is
how it brings people together people who
might not otherwise see each other it's
just really really wholesome that was
super clear to me when I went to a
massive tour in Fremont California
[Music]
there's something undeniably festive
about the Ramadan spirit and I noticed
it not just this if dark but at all the
other ones I went to as well like being
here amongst all these people it makes
it feel nice before
[Music]
here's the thing I don't want to make
Ramadan out to be just one big party
night after night its celebratory and
something people look forward to but
there's also this focus I'm training
yourself to become a better person
that's why I headed to the local Islamic
Center in Auckland that's azita she
helps run things there she's also just
an all-around awesome human being I
think she's also influenced your actions
so we packed food into boxes put on
these rad stickers and passed them out
to homeless people nearby
it's honestly something I've never done
before just roll down the window and ask
a homeless person if they wanted dinner
these are people who struggles I
couldn't even begin to imagine I chose
to fast they did not but in that moment
as I handed them a bottle of water or
to-go box of food I felt a sense of
shared humanity you know I've always
been sort of hesitant about donating
online but I don't know that experience
pushed me to be more charitable and I
guess that's the idea of Ramadan if you
do something regularly for 30 days
chances are it will become a habit even
after Ramadan is over I've never been
the most spiritual or the most
practising Muslim but Ramadan kind of
inspired me to look inward I went to
mosques I listened to the Quran I spent
some time meditating on my bed but I
don't know I just didn't feel
comfortable recording myself it kind of
felt like I needed a spiritual advisor
so I hid up in Mom's a--have weapon he
converted to Islam when he was in
college which means just like me he
fasted for the first time in his 20s
every year I fasted there's been kind of
maybe a different personal purpose right
so this year like I'm trying to move to
zero-waste lifestyle where there's no
plastics in my life and it's really
really hard but then each of us like
yourself there's this personal
construction so I would ask you what
does it mean to you if I could come up
with one word to define my experience
this Ramadan it would be is a time that
brings people together no matter what
their background who might not otherwise
see each other who may be thousands of
miles away from family who may have
different views and differing beliefs
but we all came together during Ramadan
we all fasted we all bonded over our
share connection to this pool Club 1.8
billion people and that's the main
reason I wanted to make this video I
wanted to show you that Ramadan to them
and to me isn't just solemn and
dignified and full of starvation it's a
month of celebration you celebrate your
faith your friends your family and your
blessings you celebrate the act of
helping others and you get to take part
in the most simple yet powerful
celebration of all getting together with
people you love to break bread and make
conversation
and that's why I'm off to another iftar
hey guys thanks for watching
Ramadan means so many different things
to so many different people and my
personal experience is just one of many
like 1.8 billion many so make sure to
let us know in the comments below what
Ramadan means to you and make sure to
subscribe to aj+ for more episodes of in
real life